Jim is with us in Phoenix Arizona hi Jim
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
doing today
better than I deserve what's up well my
question is um I do not I'm in my
mid-60s and I do not have a tremendous
amount of money save for retirement and
I hear these advertisements on flipping
homes with no money down and I'm
interested in your opinion of that how
it might work and where would I find
somebody that's reputable as opposed to
paying for a course and then having to
buy all their material and so on and so
forth um well you know the stories about
get-rich-quick right get right get rich
quick so good way to go broke and vast
majority of people that follow those
plans and end up broke so you've got it
you got to avoid that I mean your your
urgency to do something and play
catch-up here if you're not real careful
can lead you into a real disaster so can
you flip real estate and make money
doing that yes you can of course it has
everything to do with buying it at an
incredible deal right right and that's
the hardest part of the equation what
hands up happening is people get excited
and then they overpay for the real
estate and they finance a hundred
percent of it some way or another and
then they can't get out of it and it
bankrupts them so that zero down
flipping real estate stuff is 99% of
time a really really bad idea now if you
have the ability Jim to go out and dig
up a deal and find a bargain on a piece
of real estate you can probably find
somebody to buy your deal before you
even buy it after I went broke I did
some of that I didn't have any money and
I didn't have any credit after I went
broke but I knew how to dig up deals
because it's what I had been doing and
so I would find a piece of property and
just tie it up with a contract to
purchase it subject
- you know for four or five days I'm
going to tie it up long but subject to
my partner's agreement and then I would
just reach out to some investors and
have one of them buy it and so you know
an example would be if I bought a piece
of property for 150,000 that's worth two
hundred or worth three hundred or
whatever then I would sell it to that
investor for a hundred and seventy and
they would just give me twenty for the
contract and go close it I never
financed anything right and right how do
I that way way to do build a network of
people that potentially could be a
source for me I would start contacting
some real estate agents in the area and
ask if they have any investors that buy
property at a deal and most of them have
an investor or two in their pocket that
if they you know if I found a property
is 70 cents on the dollar would you have
a cash buyer that could close quickly it
could close in a couple days and you
know talk to some invite you know and if
you don't who in your office does does
that kind of thing and there's some good
Realtors out there that aren't working
just retail they have a few wholesale
buyers in their pocket out there some
guys that are gals that are players the
other thing is there used to be and
it'll depend on the city there might be
a club in the area a real estate
investors club in the Phoenix area I
don't know if there is or not there's
one in Nashville where I live and you
could just become a member of that Club
and get to meet some of those men and
women that do that and just talk to them
over a cup of coffee and just say you
know what if you know what if I found
the property at 70 cents on the dollar
would you give me a spread on that and
close it quickly and do you have that
cash ability and just you know you learn
some of those folks and you can again
develop I had I don't know 30 or 40
people that could do a deal like that in
my pocket back in that day and because I
never dime and that certainly would
anybody loaning me money I just come
through a bankruptcy so right but the
you know here's the thing the old the
old saying is true
money is not hard to find deals and
ideas are hard to find right and and
somebody that will work and dig it up so
if you wanted to go out and do that you
could do that
now as far as whose course to go through
Don how to dig up bargains I don't know
I haven't reviewed all of them are
audited them are going through them
personally because you know most of them
are going to spend a lot of their time
teaching you how to get deeply in debt
and of course I'm going to tell you to
avoid that but the you know digging
looking at foreclosures looking at
bankruptcy deals and doing pre
foreclosure post foreclosure which is an
REO a real estate owned a bank when a
bank owns the property what are they
going to do with it sometimes you can
get a deal there right now on the real
estate market in your area is hot and it
makes it a lot harder to find deals real
estate market in our area here in
Nashville it's very hot very hard to
find bargains right now and so you're
going to really scratch around a lot to
find you a deal or two and but it's a
fun business and you can do that but I
would highly recommend you don't use the
nothing down I'm going to flip real
estate method because you'll end up
deeply in debt stuck in a piece of
property and you know you'll set
yourself back and step forward and be
careful every time I get desperate and I
feel that urgency because I'm a little
desperate that's when I get stupid so
just avoid that thanks to you
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you